and i'm looking at where he's going he's
going into the uh
special ed class so
my best friend in elementary school
there was a kid who was mentally
challenged and i didn't you didn't even
know
i didn't [ __ ] know bless your heart
bro
so the reason why she was thanking me
for being so nice to him is because he
was the mentally challenged kid
and this fool was my best friend and i
had no [ __ ] idea
hey man that's [ __ ] sweet in
five four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
i'm your host david sow and then we have
ed parkvp in the house man what's up
we just got done eating shaboo i had a
migraine and then it went away so we're
shooting a second one
nice that's how it is this yeah i was
telling you outside
about how so we were having a
conversation about basically how scary
the ocean is
right and a lot of people don't respect
the ocean very much at
all no they you know we see these
pictures of these beautiful beaches we
see these like pristine waters
but you don't [ __ ] know there are
creatures in that ocean that will
literally
kill you the unknown yeah it's i think
they said like the
what was the comparison of um
how much the ocean is unexplored
compared to oh yeah it was like 90 per
95 of the ocean is unexplored which is
crazy
yeah so we don't know what's down there
either exactly the fear of the unknown
so in uh hawaii there's a spot that i go
to to go snorkeling right
it's a really cool spot it's not it's
not like a national park or anything
else like that
but in this area there's it's teeming
with fish and if you even get there
earlier you might even see some manta
rays
which you know people tell that to me as
if i want to see a [ __ ] match race
without me
i'm [ __ ] okay yeah you know yeah
those things are huge
it's i mean they're they're harmless
apparently but
having a i don't think people understand
when you
see a creature in the water that's it's
their element
not yours yeah and they're bigger than
you
it's [ __ ] frightening yeah that
didn't they kill the crocodile hunter
did it steven that's a stingray so manta
rays are these huge things that eat like
phytoplankton or something
and they they still don't want to be
around they're huge dude they're like
probably the size of this [ __ ] room
um but when i was going snorkeling right
so in this area
uh the waves are kind of choppy but once
you move past it the water
calms down a little bit and the water is
like crystal clear
like looking glass type of clear [ __ ]
right so from
when you look from top to bottom on a
great date which majority of the days in
that area it's nice you could see the
bottom of the seafloor right
um it's a really good snorkeling place
but we're going there
and right when i when i go off into the
water i move past the place where
there's choppy
choppy water and because it's choppy all
the sand is coming up you can't visually
see anything right it's getting murky so
right when i come out
i [ __ ] it the waves push me out past
past the clearing of the murky the murky
water [ __ ] sea tortoise right in
front of my face
i [ __ ] kiss it right in the [ __ ]
face i'm not lying
like legit are [ __ ] his beak and my
mouth met
i was like oh [ __ ] and you're not
supposed to touch dc tonight
apparently it's illegal i didn't do it
on purpose this will sexually harass you
okay i was like you know and i love
[ __ ] sea turtles yeah but i don't
want a [ __ ] tongue one yeah so
our my face smashes into this turtle and
just kind of just goes off its way
which to me when i'm swimming in the
water because i'm so scared of it i take
these small things as a bad omen yeah
like something bad is going to happen
but i'm like okay it's cool so i'm in
this water i'm already feeling a little
weird
so i'm swimming around i'm snorkeling i
see all these beautiful fish
as i'm swimming i notice there's this
moving object coming
towards me yeah and from beneath me so
this is like
30 feet maybe oh gosh this i'm already
getting anxious
and i'm swimming and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is i look down i see this huge
sea creature beneath me freaking up it's
a shark i'm done
i'm scared yeah i think this is a shark
it turns out it's a [ __ ] monk seal
so a monk ceiling it's it's it's a salt
water
i think i'll steal the salt water but
it's a seal that's an endangered species
out in hawaii and there's one that
specifically lives in a sea cave
in this area right nobody [ __ ] tells
me this [ __ ]
and it's not very common apparently that
a monk seal allows you to see it that
close i'm talking about that monk seal
how to be from like where i'm sitting to
where you are
right right i shat myself dude actually
i
bite your nose off so i'm sitting there
and i'm frozen i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
so this monk seal goes up from under me
as far as you are to me gets a gulp of
water i swear to god that
[ __ ] seal looked into the windows of
my soul
and it just stares at me and it just
goes back down into the city
i'm thinking and so i'm freaking out and
i'm trying to backpedal backwards yeah
and there's another guy that's observing
this monk so he knows that it's there
and because he's like documenting it
but looks at me he goes and we're you
know up there i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
was that he goes
that's a monk seal he goes i have never
seen somebody that close to a monk seal
they're usually really aggressive
oh my god so i'm looking at this guy and
the only thing i could think about when
i got back
so i went back to uh back to land i
didn't go back out and i was like
did that still think i was one of him
this is why this one didn't do anything
to me this one just looked at me like oh
it's another seal
it just went right back down a flight
would offend it i'm like
yeah was one of the most frightening
experiences of my life
i i can't even the entire time you're
telling the story
like deep water stories make me have
such bad anxiety
like i can't you know you already talked
about my fear of seafood
it stems from this the thalassophobia
stuff like
uh like i i got asked on a date once
to go paddle boarding and i just gave it
a shot like i'm gonna conquer oh you
went
i i'm going to conquer my fears
for some [ __ ] yeah
i i was on my board the whole time on my
hands and knees
just oh like i don't know if i could do
this
i couldn't even stand up i couldn't
stand every time i tried i
fell off and i'd freak out for being in
the water and climb back
on that board and i was just on my knees
paddling
and well paddle boarding is hard oh well
like i didn't know i was
just i knew i i i just one of those
binary thoughts like i'm going to do it
now
nope didn't work yeah i've i went paddle
boarding and i [ __ ]
landed on the side of my head and then i
had water in my ear for like five days
and i was like okay [ __ ] this thing i've
never had too many good moments in the
ocean
just just looking down there and where
it comes from to
just the entire body of it freaks me out
did you get a second date nope
no okay i matched with this other girl
and and we had a face time like yeah
we'll go out
soon and we're like oh let's follow each
other on instagram
she eats oysters like every day like
what yeah she eats
seafood every day she loves seafood and
i freak out at her instagram photos
you know and it was just tough like man
yeah like the seafood party is freaking
me out
it was enough for me to just kind of
like we we still keep in touch but then
we're i'm kind of
using the pandemic excuse me yeah it's
like but no it's because you eat sea
bugs you [ __ ] freak
is everything in the ocean dude that's
so weird
did you do you don't you don't even know
why you have that fear right you just
know it developed
yeah it just developed over time and i
can't pinpoint when
i like i know i have memories of eating
crab when i was a kid
probably ate some clams and fish fried
fish somewhere along the way i
just it just makes me want to barf so
that [ __ ]
anime tentacle porn was freaky
[Laughter]
especially not
whenever it comes on do you know the
weird thing about
hentai like uh tentacle porn like the
development of it was
there was a small documentary i think
you guys could see it on youtube but
there was
the guy that created that genre of of
cartoon perversion
is still alive now because it actually
hasn't been around for that long
but japan has weird censorship rules
for when it comes to sex right but
that's why when you see japanese porn
it's all blurred and [ __ ]
well tentacles aren't a false
it's not a penis it's not a sexual organ
so the work around that is to have these
girls [ __ ]
by tentacles so that's
how that genre developed like you could
see that documentary online on youtube
and this guy's talking about it in the
most professional way possible
yikes yeah yikes isn't that [ __ ]
weird yeah
i mean that is quite the loophole yeah
to get what you want but
i mean uh they've got weird laws
in the way okay so like you know david
cho the artist
i remember listening to his story about
why he got arrested in japan
and went to jail apparently he got
arrested for
uh graffiti but as i was looking through
his bag
there's his sketchbooks it's just the
[ __ ] up drawings of naked women and
all this weird [ __ ] that he is you know
and so they arrested him for
that stuff because it wasn't censored
right that's
hilarious he was like what the [ __ ] look
at your guy's just porn
yeah right this is my personal
sketchbook and then apparently the
couple's like
you don't know you don't know what it's
like to be us
you don't know what likes to be japanese
so don't judge us for what
for us and that was it was like oh okay
okay
he's like if this was a tentacle it'd be
a different story
if this person was being [ __ ] by a
tentacle you would be okay
right it was these weird legalism things
like
just about what's good and like what
what's fair and what's what works
and then what is straight up they say is
illegal david cho is a fascinating
character though oh yeah like if you
guys don't know who david cho is david
cho
i mean it could be kind of weird if you
don't know who he is but he's an artist
he's an amazing artist um and in fact at
fishbowl he he
created a mural right outside of it
which is so awesome it looks awesome
it's the
bourdain mural yeah uh he's
and he's probably more well known for
his podcast his crazy stories
and also that he made like 40 something
million dollars off of facebook stocks
right and i guess the story behind that
was that facebook or
zuckerberg or whoever it was contacted
him to make a mural right
and they offered him money and he said
he didn't want the money so they just
gave him some stocks
and it turns out it's now worth 40
something million dollars yeah
so crazy what kind of [ __ ] luck is
that i heard it like he doesn't say out
loud but i've heard it could be up to
like 250.
that's crazy man like i wouldn't even
know what to do with money like that
like what the [ __ ] would i do with that
i mean what's wild and admirable about
him is that he was
doing whatever he wanted to at that time
too
when he made that facebook money he was
already a millionaire
from oh yeah from his art and from his
gambling
addiction from blackjack and vegas he
said he was already a millionaire
and then he made more out of facebook
stocks
yeah when people give him [ __ ] for being
so lucky or whatever he's like
[ __ ] you dude like i was already a
millionaire yeah he already made his
money
like before then you know what's so
weird i had this conversation
and there was this thought that i had to
myself and i actually didn't see this
quote uh prior to this right but
i kept i keep hearing this thing and
there's this idea of other people
calling people lucky
right and i don't like it
when a [ __ ] loser tells somebody
who's successful
that they're lucky because what it looks
like it's like and they
and this is what it is too luck has a
for somebody to say that a hard-working
person is just lucky
it makes that person who worked hard for
everything that they had
feel terrible right right because you're
really you're overlooking the fact
of the hours that you put in to work on
something to be great at what you do
right now the argument to that is that
hey well there are other people who work
just as hard as you who didn't get to
where you are
maybe but i have yet to find that person
i'm sorry yeah and so somebody gave me
an example and i blocked this person
because this person was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
they go what are you talking about
haven't you heard of [ __ ] people who
work in the kitchen they're the hardest
workers in the room
and they don't get to be chefs yeah but
they're also dumb
right and i'm not saying that as a diss
i was that person
yeah because i'm not saying luck doesn't
play
a huge a small part in it but there's so
many other things aside from just luck
that allows somebody to be successful
because take the opportunities exactly
because it's about the opportunities
that you take and you make something out
of it
and when i talk about the person you're
talking about these persons who are
immigrants and cooks or whatever my
parents my mom was also
an immigrant who cleaned hotels or
whatever else right
so was she lucky that she somehow found
a way to run her own business
or is it because that she figured out a
way she was smart about her [ __ ]
right it's not just luck it's also hard
work it's also being very smart
so just to just to being the uh the
situation of the
of the kitchen line cookout right right
there's somebody every day that'll be
the kitchen line cook that'll cook the
food the way that the
that the sous chef or the main chef
wants you to cook it right but there's
also that line cook that's gonna
go the next step and then level up his
dishes try to figure out how to become a
sous chef
and they kind of figure out how to move
themselves up in the ring right just
because you worked hard doesn't mean
that you work smart
just because you worked hard doesn't
mean that you had the ability to become
something better at something that
you're not good at
you have to find out what your skills
are you have to find out what makes you
you
so when you tell somebody that they're
just lucky it's [ __ ] annoying
sounds like working hard is subjective
yeah
what is your version of working hard i
clocked in yeah well what did you do
when you clocked yeah
it's one of those things like when
people live fatalistically or like as if
things are destined for them
where they work hard they put their head
down and they'll get that promotion
if they don't get it someone else gets
it well that's because you put your head
down and didn't take
any of the opportunities you weren't
assertive about your stuff
yeah that's the hard thing and i think
that a lot of young people
excuse me not a lot young people a lot
of people young and adults
who stay in the same place their whole
lives they don't understand they go
i worked hard i kept my head down and i
did what i was supposed to do but did
you do more
that doesn't mean that you were the
hardest perking person working in the
room
that just means you did your job the way
that you were supposed to and you never
thought about doing something else out
of it
right so it doesn't mean that you
deserve the promotion people in
companies who get a job who get a raise
is because they exhibit and show value
right i can add value to your company
right it's never because you worked hard
because you clocked in every [ __ ]
time
[ __ ] i came to school almost all
the time
this podcast is brought to you by babel
for most of us learning a
second language in high school or
college wasn't exactly a high point in
our academic careers
melamo es muy feo por favor es muy gordo
that means welcome david you are loved
well if you want your spanish or
whatever language you want to learn to
be better than mine you're going to need
battle okay
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn new languages on
the go i do it whenever i'm pooping or
even right before i sleep which is my
favorite time to do it and it's the best
learning a language should be about
practical usage
with real world conversations and
applications in mind
and that is babel here's the coolest
thing about it too they have speech
recognition technology that helps you to
improve your pronunciation
and accent which is super and important
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months
for free yes that's six months for the
price of three just go to babel.com and
use promo code gb
that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot com
code gb for an extra three months free
babble
language for life i didn't have the
grades for it right
i wasn't the hardest person working in
the room so when people say that they
use that example of hey
um other people who work just as hard of
you isn't successful
i haven't met that person yet so when
you show me that person let me know
every hard-working individual that had a
little bit of luck
that knew where they wanted to go and
figure their way out and they were
very very smart about the things that
they did they ended up
definitely at a place higher than they
were before right so
i haven't found that and if you're
somebody who's saying that that's you
that you work hard and you're getting
nowhere it's because you [ __ ] suck
i'm sorry that's what it is
like clocking in and clocking out isn't
just the end of it showing up
isn't just the end of it exactly yeah i
think people i i've been told before too
when i was younger like it it helps to
look at your position as the ceo
of your own job right you're responsible
for everything
and if you do complete your task like
what more could you offer
too and at the same time you could see
some companies won't give you that
promotion
then go somewhere else yeah that's what
i'm saying people live in resentment for
that one company
this one time that they did and it's
like dude they didn't value yeah
move on yeah 100 and also too
at the same time and when i say you
[ __ ] suck it just might mean that
whatever place that you're
at that's what you suck at so find
something that really
is you you can work hard at something
your whole life
like you could till soil that doesn't
have any nutrients in it it doesn't mean
that fruit is going to grow
right you're going to work hard at
tilling that soil trying to grow plants
water it or whatever
but the soil soil's not fertile all
right so what the [ __ ] are you tending
to
you know what i'm wasting your time then
you're literally wasting your time peter
dinklage talked about this and then
recently
i put this tweet out two weeks before
this but elon musk said the same thing
he put out a tweet where he's like you
know i work whatever
you know 24 hours out of the day seven
days a [ __ ] week no sleep
put all this time and money but people
still say it's luck
people do that because they want to feel
good about where they're at in life and
they want to [ __ ] on what you have
right you know that's why when you tell
somebody that they're lucky in terms of
their work
it becomes it's a little annoying yeah
it's just a little it's a little
obnoxious
yeah what they have and such like that
it's uh does everyone
need did they need to know that about
you yeah
or do they need to know that about
themselves or were you just asserting
like
like having to make them re-examine
their entire life some reason because
you said so
yeah exactly and we're not we're not
saying luck doesn't play a small part
yeah i'm saying that there's other parts
to it that allowed somebody to be very
successful yeah when you just say that
somebody is lucky
that's more of a reflection on you being
upset at where you're at in your life
lucky and like chance happens 100 things
fall on your lap
how many things have fallen on people's
lap and they [ __ ] it up yeah
yeah let's talk about that so then you
can be as lucky as you want and have all
the opportunities in the world
we know them too people get a lot of
opportunity
and [ __ ] it all up too you know like and
that's not just being
lucky oh you're so lucky like how is it
it's lucky at the end of the day he's
[ __ ] up too
yeah right and a lot of people too like
to take the exception to the rule
because in another example they go what
about people who were just born into
wealth
i was like are you that [ __ ] loser
that looks at all the negative things in
life and then you
that you sit there and you wallow in
self-pity because you don't have what
they have
or are you going to be the hardest
working person in that room and get what
they have
i know it sounds overly simplistic right
it really does
and but i'm telling you when you when
you work hard you work smart and you
find these opportunities
and you capitalize on them you may not
not everybody will reach
up to their wildest dreams but you will
reach a certain level of success
you know and that that's really what it
is
even the stuff that i have now it's
because of hard work like
there's other people youtube was there
for everybody yeah everybody had the
same luck
you could have signed up and put up your
own stuff too right exactly everybody
else could have done the same thing you
did
yeah and it was a free open medium yeah
there was people too that i
specific specifically on my platform i
attempted and tried to put on
and they did not it didn't work for them
so they had the same luck i did
yeah and in fact their luck was actually
given to them because they met me
and i pushed their [ __ ] harder than
nobody pushed my [ __ ] yeah
it was a video that did well and then i
capitalized on it and then i started
building upon it
and so for those other people they met
me i pushed their stuff they didn't go
anywhere
why because they weren't the hardest
working person in the room
they weren't smart about their [ __ ] you
know it's just a weird concept like i
just hate hearing that [ __ ]
yeah i mean the other way around
sometimes like even at my store
people just kind of looking at me
as like a loser yeah that i
uh oh you make minimum wage you [ __ ]
lose someone actually told me that [ __ ]
at work decent my storm yeah like
yeah i dude i live here i work here this
my like my family's owned this place
and they go [ __ ] and i'm like i
don't understand these people honestly
like why would they
say this [ __ ] yeah and it's the same
type of people
whether you want to tell someone that
they're lucky for everything you got
or you're just a piece of [ __ ] you don't
make move it kind of sounds like the
same
attitude it is yeah it's a reflection
of you projecting yourself maybe yeah
it's just the dumbest thing because i've
never heard a winner say
well it's only because you're lucky oh
they never say that
yeah i've never heard a hard-working say
working person say that to somebody else
they don't they don't have time to
because they don't think it it's what i
hear about
um certain like millionaires and
billionaires or something right
like i don't like how in ufc
people have beef right but they get in
that octagon and for the fact that that
they went
in there and locked the cage and duked
it out one of them lost whatever
you will see this crazy respect right
for the fact that they went in
in the first place i i read about how a
lot of
these like ultra wealthy people
actually respect each other very much
because of like they know what it takes
to get there
yeah they they don't have to ask each
other for money they don't need money
from each other
yeah you know and that's one of those
things that i learned like
they're not [ __ ] digging at each
other apparently like
as much as we we might think they are
yeah yeah they don't
they don't care yeah because they
understand what it takes to get there
we're not talking about these trust fund
babies
right we're talking about people who had
to figure out a way to make their wealth
they understand how hard it is to to to
get to where they're at
so they're not gonna [ __ ] on somebody
else who went through the same trials
and tribulations that they went through
it's more of a mutual understanding
that's like when we talk about ufc
fighters like the thing that always
makes it so
odd for me is when two fighters go in
and they beat the living [ __ ] out of
each other then they hug after
yeah i'm let me tell you something you
punched me in my face that much you'll
never hug me
get the [ __ ] out of my face right but
it's because they understood the grind
they have this weird like this this
kindred spirit when it comes to
understanding how painful it is
yeah for them to work this hard to get
into this cage and duke it out
and once all once that's all said and
done somebody comes as a winner and
loser
they hug it out because it's like dude
it's done done it's over finally
because they actually like we see 15
minutes of it right
they see [ __ ] 90 days of it
of all that training all that diet all
that weight cut
and then for that 15 minutes yeah dude
this is a complete side note and i know
this has nothing to what we're talking
about but dude i had the weirdest
[ __ ] revelation recently
okay i just remembered it right now and
i was sitting in the car
thinking about how there's there's a
duality to this right there's one
thought of how [ __ ] dumb i am
and a second thought of how innocent
children are right
and i spoke on this podcast before about
how
i had a friend in elementary school who
i met later on in life and i didn't
realize
that he had a thick like filipino accent
until i was an adult okay because when
you're a kid
he's just your friend right and you're
hanging out life is good or whatever
so this dude that i met um because he
was asking me for life advice he heard
that i got successful in terms of you
know whatever his version of success is
not
my definition of success yeah but he was
like hey like i need some guidance like
you were somebody who just kind of
pursued what he wanted to do and this is
through text
you pursued what you wanted to do and
i'm in this space right now where i'm at
a job i don't like
and i keep hearing about what you're
doing and you know i could use some
advice
i haven't talked to this dude since like
freshman year of high school
yeah but i do remember how good of
friends we were when we were younger
so i was like okay cool let's meet up
when i'm in sacramento i'm coming
through through thanksgiving
let's chop it up meet up with this dude
david it's been so long
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is yeah
this how are you you know
you know i haven't seen you in for a
bear and i'm like what
the who the [ __ ] is that who am i with
like what is with this thick ass [ __ ]
accent dude
and i just i was like holy [ __ ] he had
that accent when we were kids but when
you're a kid
you're not really looking at those
differences you're just like enjoying
your friend's company
yeah i had this revelation and i just
remembered this
not a revelation this revelation
happened in high school but i remembered
um having this revelation in high school
yeah and being thinking
these really weird conflicting thoughts
so check it out
when i was at in high school my freshman
year
right i had this very weird moment where
there's this one girl who has a
fraternal twin
right okay so this girl comes up to me
and the last time i saw her was
actually in elementary school and it was
the first elementary school i went to
before i got expelled
and removed to another school for
fighting so with her she comes up to me
and she goes
david and i remember her because i
thought she was always thought she was
super cute and this is in elementary
school
when i was like in third grade yeah i
probably had like a lightweight crush on
her and so she goes david
i'm like whoa you remember me she goes
yeah i remember you
i was like well how have you been she
goes yeah we're going to the same high
school now
we start chopping it up and she goes
i've always wanted to say this to you
since i was
since i was a kid she goes thank you for
being so sweet to my brother
and i'm like well yeah i was like your
brother is your brother i was like yeah
we were like best friends
she goes yeah you were just you know you
were so sweet to me and you didn't have
to do that and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
we're friends right i couldn't put two
and two together
and so later on i see her brother on
campus
right and he's with like a group of
students that are walking in a straight
line
he runs up to me and he's just like
saying my name david but he's looking at
the floor kind of looking down and
whatever
like whatever and he looks a little odd
i was like hey
what's up bro have you been and he's you
know kind of
just looking around looking at the floor
smiling really happy to see me but not
making eye contact
and then one of the teachers come over
and tell them to get back in line he
goes back in line
and i'm looking at where he's going he's
going into the
special ed class so
my best friend in elementary school was
a kid who was mentally challenged and i
didn't you didn't even know i
didn't [ __ ] know bless your heart bro
so the reason why she was thanking me
for being so nice to him is because he
was the mentally challenged kid
and this fool was my best friend and i
had no [ __ ] idea hey man that's
[ __ ] sweet
[Laughter]
he thought i was also [ __ ]
she was like man you guys are getting
red well she's like thank you for being
so nice to my brother
i'm like why so he was like my best
friend and i had no
[ __ ] clue as a kid wow well i mean
that's there's a beauty to that that why
i say bless your heart
because even at i don't know if i told
this story before at my store
where this big guy came in
um uh wanting to use the bathroom
right and i'm stalking beer in the back
and i just hear the conversation where
he's like hey do you guys have a
bathroom
my mom goes number one or number two
and he's like bathroom do you have a
bathroom
my mom's like number one or number two
we had problem
last problem with number two yeah number
one okay
and he goes bath room do you
have a bathroom it was number one
and i'm like i've had it at this point
yeah i get out of the back
i say number one or number two he turns
on and sees me and he's like
oh yeah number one and i was like what's
wrong with the way she said it and why
do you understand me
and he doesn't answer and just goes and
use my bathroom anyway
i turn to my mom i'm really upset i'm
like
god that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
know my mom's like
don't be like that to the customers i
was like no [ __ ] that um
like that [ __ ] guy's being a racist
to you yeah she goes
laces i thought he's mental handicapped
i'm like all right i guess i should
adopt your mentality
like just leave it like and then i just
kind of thought about like that too
you just treat racist people it's just
like you know what
you're just you're just dumb dude you're
[ __ ] dumb
you won't hear something worse about
this that's my story yeah
so there was somebody else in elementary
school that was also my really close
friend yeah right
so in high school around um sophomore or
junior year
i saw this kid so in elementary school
this kid was
everybody remembers him if they went to
my same elementary school i'm not going
to say his name
but he was very well known for being a
really weird kid he had
huge [ __ ] ears and he dressed up like
pee-wee herman
right red bow tie gray suits suspenders
fenders and he always dressed like that
every time to school
so he used to get bullied a lot but he
was actually like my really really good
friend right
so i see this fool in high school like
sophomore or junior year
right same thing i'm like yo what's up
how have you been he goes
and he's talking to me looking at the
floor all weird you know talking stuff
this kid was also one of the special
agents
he was also my other best friend and i'm
like
doc dude where the [ __ ] is going were
you in special ed
i don't know maybe they put you in
special ed too
you have to learn esl this kid
this kid this podcast is brought to you
by
raycon my friends if you are looking for
affordable
wireless earbuds that are absolutely
amazing that's not going to break
your bank we are talking about raycon i
have been using my raycons wherever i go
whether i'm on
a walk whether i'm listening to a
podcast whether i'm working out oh and
especially when i bike it's
super lightweight it charges really fast
and let me tell you something right now
man
raycon's 24 hour battery life and
portability is probably the best thing
that i
like about them they're super small and
compact and i could take them
anywhere especially when i'm on my daily
grind
son i don't want no wires if you have
wired earbuds why don't you go
into a time machine and punch yourself
in your face what are you doing do you
also listen to your music on an a-track
get raycon earbuds i love them with
all of my life and summer's coming up
baby you know you're going to need some
wireless earbuds they sound crisp
they're amazing and they're powerful
and they are half the price of other
premium audio brands so check it out
listen up
raycon's offering 15 off all their
products for my listeners and here's
what you got to do to get it go to buy
raycon.com
brain there you'll get 15 off your
entire recon order
and it's such a good deal you want to
grab a pair and a spare that's 15
off at byraycon.combrain
by raycon dot com slash brain it shocked
me
this one for real shocked me like i was
like no
[ __ ] way because he i remember he
used to get bullied because of how he
dressed and stuff
but this was the kid that used to give
me funyuns all the time
because his parents owned like a liquor
store like a convenience store
so he would always come with these bag
of funyuns his fool would like bait me
oh you're my best friend yeah i was like
yo this is the funyun kid he would
always hook me up with funyuns
and then anybody who would try to bully
him i would tell him to leave him alone
so i think he was using me with food as
like a guard dog
but then he's the one that's the [ __ ]
mentally challenged kid he was baiting
me
hey that's pretty smart dude
yo two times in high school this
happened and then and i kind of blocked
this thought out i don't know why it
struck me out of nowhere but i
remembered in high school
those two moments that happened i'm like
holy [ __ ] my two best friends in
elementary school
were a part of the special ed class i
had no [ __ ] idea how short was your
bus ride
how short was the bus
like we rode the same bus we had to say
lunch time
we had recess together while the other
kids had their own questions
wear helmets all the time it was crazy
like i i kind of want to go back into my
elementary school
like if you look up like what classes
that i take
but i'm also a little scared yeah
i was so worried you know what though i
i
dated a special ed teacher and man
she was awesome she was great okay yeah
and part of me wished i went to special
ed when i was a kid
honestly i actually told this to her
because
of the way i grew up with my adhd and
like just the hyper activity all that
i kind of wish someone would have been
like pulled me aside like hey let's sit
down and work on this
yes if i took those classes at a young
age i think it would have helped me
just seeing like her how she works with
her kids and all that
i don't think it's anything to be
ashamed of if you took special ed
guys it's i like to call my spells my
call myself special ed
like i'm special too i just feel so
i just felt so weird that i was used by
a kid who was in special ed class to
protect him with fungus
and i didn't see it until i became an
adult
[Laughter]
could you imagine how related and the
reason i remember too when he
approached me he remembered me because i
was like one of his best friends
and i knew that he was wasn't of
normal mental capacity because he was
still dressed the same way that he did
when he was in elementary school
i'm talking about when we were like six
seven eight years old because his
parents would dress him
they're still dressing him when he was
15 or 16 years old
you know what though they remembered you
because you were kind
yeah that's for sure because there's
this guy
after holy [ __ ] decades he still
remembers me too
uh we were in youth group together he
was uh
a special i don't know what the word is
but
his brain function was that of like an
eight-year-old
okay so but he can drive apparently uh
uh he takes care of himself very well
he's clean and all that [ __ ] but like
um he loves transformers power rangers
all that so he's very much an
eight-year-old
he feels like literally you right now
what are you talking about right now
people are listening right now they're
like that's me
he can try he loves transformers all
these [ __ ] dudes are listening to
this podcast
oh [ __ ] no but um every time i
visit home he remembers me like um and
he's very nice and
but the thing is he does talk about my
ex from like 20 years ago
so i think his mental capacity could
still be back in those days
yeah that's probably how they remember
you too someone who was nice to them
that's why they had to
run and come see you yeah i mean i'm
telling you david bless your heart
yeah that's why she was like thank you
for being so sweet to him i'm like
and my mom i'm like of course he's my
best friend yeah so
i don't know what he's talking about i
had a very
innocent outlook on life when i was a
kid right that's what i'm starting to
realize
because even for me too when it came to
the idea of like
like sex and stuff i wasn't very like
horny as a little kid either
right maybe that's all that's why you
know as we're adults we're sifting
through our thoughts and minds
when we meet other people we're seeing
how other other guys are like when i was
a kid
i wasn't like hypersexual either like i
never
yeah you know i [ __ ] jacked off i got
really horny and stuff of course but the
amount of times that the
my other male peers but like the homies
would talk about [ __ ]
girls sex titties i generally didn't
really give a [ __ ]
i couldn't understand like why these
guys
as as a high schooler too like that
wasn't my realm i mean maybe because i
was a high school virgin
but it wasn't my realm at all like
that's all they would talk about i was
more or less like
oh like this makes me feel uncomfortable
i could be the christian upbringing
it's probably the christian upbringing
yeah you know but
not saying i didn't jack off either it
was hilarious to you can go to youth go
and be like do you jack off
like no yeah come on you're a liar yeah
i think it's easier to just understand
like hey we all do it
and anyone who says that they don't are
liars
it's like those guys too it's like dude
i never i've never watched porn
that means you watch the most disgusting
[ __ ] on earth
you watch the most perverse things you
watch human centipedes yeah
yeah because i i've said on this pa i
don't really watch much porn anymore
right like i do every now and then
occasionally but i don't know like i
don't know i think
you can get tired of it i think it was
there was a certain point too i remember
when the internet was very accessible
and i think i just got tapped out from
that right that was like a year or two
of that [ __ ] and i think it was probably
almost close to a porn addiction
because you just watched it every day
every i don't even think watching it
every day is an addiction but it's like
you just be horny all the time to watch
it you know right and then after a while
it's just like
i think here we get addicted to the
dopamine yeah
and it's a quick fix right and the
hilarious thing is
like it's about the journey because when
you finish
you're like so [ __ ] like you have
this sense of clarity like you
just what did i do kind of thing and you
and the porn addiction puts you in the
cycle of shame and
grossness and weirdness but you're horny
as [ __ ] or whatever and
the apparently the thing with this next
generation is that they're just exposed
to
all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] on the internet
and they just think that's sex
and so they're like that they get [ __ ]
up from it
and i remember thinking like even as
christians when let me tell don't jack
off don't jack off don't check off oh no
i jacked off oh yeah
that's the only reason that's the only
thing that kept me sane you know what a
loophole is
what it's not a sin
to jack off to lawn mowers what
how can you lost lawn mowers
how can you lust after an enamel like
just
inanimate object did that be so funny
you would just mow the lawn and then you
just piled the grass to look like
titties i'm like
who am i lusting after what mother earth
oh i don't know
you think it looks like tits but it's
just grass it's just a mound of grass
yeah where i put two cherries on top of
it what the [ __ ] the problem here
that's what i would say is it a sin if
you're like thinking about
you know a weed whacker and then but
you're not thinking about
a girl or whatever that makes you turned
on dude can i
i told this on the podcast before and i
think i told this when i was a little
drunk
but and i i instantly regret it but i'm
telling the story again because i really
don't give a [ __ ] anymore
i remember when i was like in high
school like i would get
you know those [ __ ] random boners
those [ __ ] rbs
nrbs and rbs no reason boners like for
no reason like i'd be at my parents
store just pissed that i had to work
here
and also my dick would be hard what the
[ __ ]
and the only reason we'll go away if i
jacked off so i would just run to the
bathroom real quick and just knock one
out
and i would just cut back all
i sleepy jack off at the [ __ ] wig
store only because my
my [ __ ] hard on wouldn't go away you
got some hair gel on your pants kid
yeah no i don't know leave me alone
and it would be the worst too because
i'd be in the store and there'd be some
[ __ ] financed women that walk in
every now and then i'm like oh [ __ ]
excuse me for a second yeah you know go
away real quick
dude it was just so weird but that's the
one thing i don't miss
is the constant no reason boners do you
know how to get rid of them i wish i
knew this when i was a kid no
flex your quads oh really push all the
blood to the quads
and then it like it goes down oh really
apparently that's the trick
just sit there and like work on filling
blood into your hands i actually had a
no reason boner
a couple days ago yeah and it was when i
was getting a massage
are you sure that's no reason no trust
me trust me
this massage lady look like the wicked
witch
this is very haggardly i mean very sweet
lady but she was an older lady too it's
like
nothing but she was massaging me and
then all of a sudden
i got a boner but i was face down and it
was so uncomfortable but the only thing
i could think about was just the here's
the hard part right
so when you're getting a massage in your
face down you're getting this boner
you could usually do a reset if you just
calm down and breathe
right but this lady's touching me yeah
it doesn't matter what she looks like
i'm not looking at her
it's yeah it's sensitive it's just it's
just soft hands touching me
and so every time like if i could feel
my dick go down a little bit
she starts touching me to go right back
up so she's like
all the time and i'm like please just i
can't
have her stop me she goes can you turn
over now i can't turn around and have my
card not yet and so my saving grace was
that when she was uh massaging me she
went to my calves and it
hurt so bad my dick just died
for my thank [ __ ] god dude i used to
go to this place every week in k-town i
had a membership there
um because i had really bad knots in my
back and so i
usually go and get this i just do some
deep tissue work on me
and this one week though he's kind of
feeling
um my stomach and it's like pretty
bloated it was pretty big at that time
and so he's massaging around my stomach
and i can just feel
him pushing down in my gut and i'm like
oh my god i'm gonna
[ __ ] fart right like i'm gonna hold
it right i'm like
resisting him he's like oh just let it
go
just let it go right and i'm i'm
still resistant and he's pushing his
fingers deep down almost like into my
spine
from the front and he goes
[Music]
like if you have to fart just so he
knows yeah he knows he goes
that's when somebody's holding their
heart just fart and then so i let it rip
right and then he goes
[Laughter]
he just congratulate congratulations
when i was in uh taiwan we we stopped by
to get a massage from this one massage
place
dog one of the worst experiences of my
life because i got this older gentleman
you know how you farted yeah well guess
what happens when you're [ __ ] massage
therapist farts don't stop
this dude i listen you don't need to
understand my taiwanese mandarin
to hear a man walk outside ripwood and
start giggling
i [ __ ] farted i [ __ ] you not like 30
times
and he couldn't stop laughing so my
massage for the time being
was literally cut in half because he had
to keep going outside to fart
what was going on with this i don't know
but this dude was kept laughing and
farting at the same time just massaging
me and [ __ ]
he just had some milk he probably
lactose it was so weird i was like dude
this is the worst massage ever this guy
is [ __ ]
literally gas tanking my ass right now
and he's massaging me
it's so weird i've had massages in
uh in china at once actually where a
dude
was massaging me so well that i [ __ ]
fell asleep he was going at it and he
was working on my legs but i don't know
what the [ __ ] he did i just
conked out and apparently he just kept
going while i was passed out and just
massaged through
i don't even know what he did that's the
first and only time i've ever slept
through a massage and i felt [ __ ]
great
yeah everywhere i've been i think i got
a massage in
um in japan and it was like a shiatsu
massage yeah and that [ __ ] hurts so
[ __ ] bad that these people were
laughing at me because i was in
literal pain oh yeah and they and you
know i can't speak japanese but mariel
can
and so mariel is talking to the guy
talking to me she's like they're
laughing because you're in so much pain
and you're twice my size
i was like they were [ __ ] my ass up
though but mario likes
really hard massages which i i like
deep tissue massages but not that deep
tissue this guy was [ __ ]
me up dude i need the deep tissue
really yeah because the high stress
um he was explaining to me like
something with a stress disorder too um
something down my back
i have a lot of these weird bumps like
knots
and so i felt like you know what i have
to go through the pain
it has to hurt like to loosen it up and
to be honest like i
i sit through it and it does hurt but i
come out much better
yeah i feel better i don't feel like uh
you know just a little
wobbling my arm and [ __ ] i can't deal
with that dude i hear so many stories
about
like happy ending massages i've never
gotten one never got one and i've always
wanted to know what it is i don't know
where to get it
i don't know where to go i don't know
how to do it i don't know what these
people are talking about
so i don't know if this is true or not
but they say that generally
any place that has like closed door
um massage areas like
80 to 70 chance that most likely they'll
give you a happy ending
like if you if you ask them for it okay
they'll do it
i don't know how true that is i don't
want to just figure it out i would
i don't know but i always wondered too
it's like do you get to choose who your
massage therapist is
or does or people who get the happy
ending they don't really give a [ __ ]
they just close their eyes they get one
it doesn't matter what the lady looks
like
it's like another job here because
exactly and they just whack it off and
then you move on
i have no [ __ ] because i've never
been around i mean i look around even
the
every of all the places i've been to
never
felt uh touched inappropriately never
let me tell you this though i know i
think i know of a place that does one
but i'm not quite sure but i got kind of
pissed off so
there's a place that i used to go to a
lot pretty frequently right
i've gone there multiple times never
been offered this service at all right
so i go with kalief right and then we
get a massage but he's he
gets a massage in another room and so
after
the massage done everything's cool this
place i go to i went like maybe twice a
month
right or maybe two years straight after
we come out i'm talking to khalif i'm
like hey bro how'd you like your massage
place is really dope right he goes bro
that [ __ ] was uncomfortable i'm like why
i was like dude this girl was like
rubbing her [ __ ] on me
like she was like massaging the [ __ ] and
i think she was offering
like sexual services uh when i was like
what the [ __ ] really what was happening
i was like bro
she got she was like grazing my balls
doing all this other [ __ ]
and the first thing i thought was i've
been going here for four years
i've never been offered this what the
[ __ ] i think
it could be just if the girl likes you
she'll offer it what's what's wrong
she literally sexually harassed him wow
i was so offended i went back i was like
i need yeah for me yeah
been here for four years never had that
happen to me either honestly
when i was in vegas well this is kind of
my fault like i don't know
this is where that innocence kind of
comes in i've i've seen things but when
it comes like sexual perversion it's
really
i'm not really big into it right so yeah
i uh
so tim and i went to send foods for to
vegas to get uh
to shoot like a few episodes um this is
like at 11 o'clock at night
um the indoor spas are closed so they
don't have any massage people working
in the in the hotels right in the suites
or anything else like that so you have
to wait till tomorrow
my back is [ __ ] up i've been flying in
a plane constantly like just going from
state to state to state eating [ __ ]
food
great food but [ __ ] food in terms of
health so i'm looking for a massage
place and i find like
one place open off the strip and i go
there
obviously it's late at night neon signs
and i'm like
cool he's like hey do you have an
availability for massage
they go okay i was like yeah i just need
an hour like deep tissue
she goes oh not that place
and i went excuse me she was like we
don't have massage not not here
and i'm like what's the sign so what the
[ __ ] are you talking about she goes
not that kind of massage i'm like oh
okay well i was like well can you guys i
don't need that
i just want she goes no no i get
[ __ ] denied so i go to a i google
another place
i uber to the other spot same [ __ ] they
don't
they're like no like not it's not not
this time
so what i'm finding out is that they
don't want
these spots that hook it up like that
they're not going to do an hour worth of
massage for half the price for what they
could do in 10 minutes
because they don't want to work like
late night these girls just want to jack
somebody off
do their business they get paid twice as
much as they did before
for like literally a tenth of the time
so i [ __ ] finally found one and i got
a massage but it took like 30 minutes
i was so pissed i was like i just want a
regular massage
somebody gave me an actual massage can
someone not try to jack me off please
yeah i don't need that i can do that i
can do it myself
so [ __ ] funny man i [ __ ] up on that
one you just sleep on your put your hand
under your seat
yeah make your hand go to sleep get
yourself a stranger
and in certain parts of asia because i
know like prostitution is legal
right right and so i think it's like
it's like even like i don't want to say
it's government
but you could tax it it's like a taxable
business or something but i heard
that over there in certain parts of asia
it's actually pretty
like classy it's yeah that's
i think someone had talked about it some
comedian how
it's also legal in australia oh is it
yeah and so it
is run by the government okay it's
regulated just like
how alcohol marijuana exactly yeah yeah
yeah they
regulate prostitution it like keeps the
women safer
um all of them are government workers so
they have all these health benefits
um like all these people basically who
would otherwise shoot up a school just
get their rocks off and then they're
great isn't that crazy yeah
because i had a buddy and i'm not
talking about like these seedy third
world country areas i'm talking about a
business it has a front stand it is for
what it is
there's there's it's a functioning
[ __ ] business yeah we're not talking
about like young children being there or
anything like these are full-grown
adults that
are in the sex industry so
uh he told me that when he walked into
this place he didn't know what to expect
because it was his friend who lived in
asia that took him to the spot
right but he said it was like a full-on
service he would go in
the you get to choose it's like rush
hour where you get to choose the type of
woman that you want
i heard it was like a noraebang book
like karaoke like there's photos
yeah and then he gets to choose a woman
gets the woman they come in they said
that this girl he said that this girl
scrubbed his body
like showered him like scrubbed his body
from head to toe
right dried him off put out put slippers
on him in her [ __ ] robe
and then took him to another room and
then [ __ ] jacked him off and then he
went into another like
a hot tub spa area got like a manicure
and pedicure
like it's like a long yeah it's like a
full-on service with jack with jacking
off yeah
yeah but a lot of businessmen go there
or something huh
maybe it's different culture yeah like
where we're all caught up
in like you know sanctity of
monogamy and all these but we all know
every single millionaire
out there is just [ __ ] around anyway
yeah it's maybe it's just like let's
just get over this [ __ ]
well we have this thing in this country
where nudity is
weird here right because you know for
like korean jim jibbons and stuff you're
butt [ __ ] naked those balls dick out
everything yeah
but over here like if you go to like a
sonic you're not going to be showing
your dick and balls out like that
we were gonna talk about mortal kombat
weren't we
what i want to mention about that is
that it's rated r it's
[ __ ] violent as [ __ ] zero sexuality
oh that's very american ain't it yeah
it's [ __ ] rated
it's so graphic right but
like to your point there's no nudity
there's no like
sexuality we forgot we were supposed to
talk about mortal kombat
we literally had that conversation
before we had this podcast before you
always go off and talk well we just
don't talk about it
we could just go into it right here yeah
so we were having this conversation
before where
there's a couple of films that wrote
that but we're not going to be able to
talk about the other one in this yeah
it's going to be too long but mortal
kombat came out recently right uh
if you guys don't know what mortal
kombat is mortal kombat is based off of
this video game
when we when we were playing it at the
time was it on super nintendo or uh n16
no it was on
it was at the arcade and then i think uh
what was that
sega genesis because super nintendo was
too
weak it couldn't play it that well yeah
yeah and so we were
mortal kombat was a huge part of our
childhood right and at that time that
was gore level crazy
right you see blood splattering out with
these like [ __ ]
pixelated blood spitting out you up cut
someone's head off
or you a secret fatality would they fall
off the stage and there's spikes below
yeah yeah this was like unprecedented
video gaming exactly so we had
our mortal kombat movie when we were a
kid and that movie was terrible
it was [ __ ] hot garbage but as a kid
i loved it oh
i loved it as a kid i watched it over
and over again on vhs dude you know what
the funny thing was about the original
mortal kombat
uh was it was it a trilogy or was it
only two there was only two
yeah so the second film was how fast
johnny cage died
that [ __ ] was hilarious yeah because he
played such a gangster ass role in the
first film
but literally throws a kick and he gets
his back snapped was it the same actor
or would
they was it because they couldn't get
the same actor they had someone else in
their like that's just [ __ ]
off this guy i think it was that like
they couldn't get the same actor so they
just killed him off
right i mean the the you look back 1995
mortal kombat
like it was huge but one of the things
that
as a fifth grader or however old we were
back then
like it wasn't violent that was the
biggest complaint right
i mean yes there's blood and such but
things happen off camera but what we
knew about mortal kombat was just
that gore yeah and this new one
definitely delivers on the gore well a
lot of people were hyper critical about
this mortal kombat film yeah
and i know when we talk about films and
it seems that we're very critical about
films but like i always say too
i watch a film ex just sometimes you
have to know what you're gonna get into
right i don't expect to watch fast and
the furious
and expect to watch amazing dialogue
which is things that
adhere to the the reality of physics
yeah like this is not what you go
in to watch this you want to see some
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was going i watched mortal kombat in
the same eye that i went to go watch
the fast and furious films right i want
to see some dope ass action and i wanted
gratuitous violence right i pretty much
got that got all that
so when people were complaining about oh
my god the story doesn't make sense
the regular mortal kombat story is
[ __ ] stupid in general dude what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
it's it's literally blood sport right
and blood sport
is fun for us as kids as an adult this
movie's pretty dumb
it is a whole lot of these tournament
fighting movies
do you remember best of the best oh yeah
that's that one too
i mean you know what's gonna happen
immediately
it's a it's a movie about people going
into
a ring and fighting so you know the
beginning middle and end
yeah except in this one they don't
actually get into the tournament
yeah that's right they didn't break the
rules
yeah it it has all these weird story
charts true
it's hard to watch but then you have to
look at it and how it's written
dude this was written for kids yeah it's
made for 10 year old boys like
i would have [ __ ] loved this movie
when i was
10 10 years old yeah i think i would
have loved it
i think i was mentioning how in this day
and age so many parents have already
shown their kids deadpool
oh yeah dude my dad showed me robocop
terminator 2 uh jason freddie cougar
jaws i saw these radar movies with my
dad
as i was watching this schloppy movie
it's rated r
and all its violence it was kind of
nonsense but then it just made me
remember like
my dad really you know my dad
bought us resident evil 2 behind my
mom's back
that's so [ __ ] funny all these
violent things that we lived through
and the media we consumed it was just
stuff my dad liked and knew we knew we
liked it
and we were cool with it we knew it
wasn't like real real
and that's what i was seeing when i
watched this mortal kombat made me think
about how my dad showed us these
floppy action movies because he loved it
yeah he loved it
and that was thing i know it's not a
great story
yeah i don't understand what people were
expecting and i know that people
follow the mortal kombat game and they
have like the cg cinematics that are
within the game that tell the story yeah
because if you put together all the cg
cinematics within the game it's like a
three hour film
and you watch it and i so this is what i
did after i watched and i was hearing
hearing or reading all these complaints
about how stupid the story is and how
much the game story is so much better
yeah i actually went on youtube and
somebody put together all the cg
stories this is pretty [ __ ] stupid
too
i was like this is [ __ ] dumb too yeah
how [ __ ] dare you
what the what were you expecting yeah
the same reason why i also say like when
people hate wwe yeah right when they
really hate
all this fake fighting no [ __ ] [ __ ] no
[ __ ] it's
rated tv 14. you know
who do you think it's for you know how
did they ever get
away with all those nip slips that would
happen here and there oh
attitude era probably in the 90s yeah i
just remember tdma
i would just wait when you have for a
nip slip so hard
that's why everyone was tuning in yeah i
was like please just slip a nipple right
[ __ ] now dude
but we have to understand going back to
that like
oh it's fake fighting it's not real
right hey batman's not real either
true superman's not real either and dark
knight was a great movie but he's not
real you know just because something's
not real then
say that about every single movie ever
made it's not real
because like where do you draw the line
i know and when you talk about the
premise of mortal kombat right then
think about it
it's a movie about a bunch of people
coming together
to kill each other to save the world is
the corniest [ __ ] thing you've ever
heard in your life
yeah come on yeah and then as you you
see the corn because of the way
this guy like how does this appeal to
kids
because this guy this main character
gets beat the [ __ ] up yeah all the time
every fight scene he gets his ass kicked
his trait
is that he always gets back up so when
he gets his powers conquer i didn't know
that was a more competing though
i became like power rangers all of a
sudden yeah but yeah his
suit quote unquote which i didn't know
was a mortal kombat thing either
yeah was his trait like you know to a
kid i can imagine a kid like who's being
bullied who always loses his fights but
you know what what it teaches them i
would have saw that that way too
like i think i would have liked that uh
character the main character what's his
name
louis louis yeah i just know that i
don't know his actual the character name
though yeah
that's how little i was paying attention
i don't remember his name either
yeah but it is what it is it's for
children and if you hate it as an adult
and you let us know you hate it
then it's like okay you hit a kid's
movie it's like yeah when i say i hate
finding dory
yeah i mean that that movie though it's
just
how could you hate that scorpion
sub-zero fight that's so good
every fight scene was good the cg was
[ __ ] amazing
yeah come on what what more did you want
from this man
like i mean they even gave us the get
over here thing
even though this man is clearly japanese
and speaks no english
he spends like two thousand years in
hell
and he packed and learned one english
phrase
get over here and by the way he says it
with no accent
his english is perfect when it comes to
that but it's like
dave is the only thing they taught me in
here get over here
[Music]
like demons are like you gotta know this
one thing if you go up there man
all right i know it's so fun then the
weird thing is so his ancestor like
understands him
just so just so you're just so he knows
who you are
the weird thing too is like i didn't
know that sub-zero's clan
has this crazy power where they can
control ice
but [ __ ] scorpion's clan has nothing
no he can
he can control rope yeah like
i was like wait hold on this is fun what
the [ __ ] is this
because i i thought that scorpion's
powers like his whole clown would
control fire so fire and ice but it's
only him because he went to hell he went
to hell
and controlled hellfire controls yeah he
said something like that
yeah hilarious so i was like how is this
even a fair a fair rivalry these people
could just kill you whenever
they're just making the icicles yeah now
you're fighting the undead
you know so wait sub-zero character was
he
an undead two or something yeah i don't
know
for me it's almost just the little minor
details are more confusing to me than
tennant
i i think we want to like this movie too
much but like
yeah this is problems i expected nothing
from the film i got
something yeah that's as much as i can
say is that
i shouldn't have expected more than i
thought yeah i mean come on man i mean
this film
it's it's like i said i'll always go
back to this it's [ __ ] called mortal
kombat yeah
what did you expect what does that even
mean what is that exactly what does that
mean
when nobody really dies how many people
died in the movie
like main characters uh there was that
kang
yeah kung lao died technically i guess
he got his soul stolen yeah
and then uh he sliced up that girl in
half with his head with his hair who was
she
i don't know there was a few characters
like i didn't know who they were
they have no ogoro died he got
bethel had the sorriest character arc in
that whole [ __ ] film dude
just shows up yeah prince goro thank you
for blessing us with your presence
now go kick some [ __ ] ass okay yeah
big deal
he's gonna be a big deal watch what
happens and gets his [ __ ]
gutted like a [ __ ] fish and then when
i saw louis tan's power i'm like
what is your superhero name the great
abuser
you just keep on getting abused
constantly that's like your power bro
i think they kind of just jacked black
panther's powers
oh were they absorbing
if i was him i'd be kind of pissed
that's why at the end of the movie
it seemed like ah so ragtag team hey
like we're like a family like all these
misfits come together and they're like
the good guy team going into the
tournament
yeah like all of a sudden it was like
ending like avengers
yeah that's true yeah and jax didn't get
his power to get either the film
because he just had his arms yeah he
just has robot arms right or oh no the
robot arms is his thing yeah yeah so
i guess his powers were that he added
more material to his weekly views
i don't know it just came out yeah
that's what it was because it was like
these tiny little
weak arms yeah and then when his powers
activated it made these crazy
yeah apparently the people who made
stefan steppenwolf's costume
the snyder cut they did his arms too so
that's why it looks all like
shreddery and [ __ ] oh that makes sense
yeah
dude that has a whole lot to do with
warner brothers hbo max probably used
the same
likes probably i mean that's why the cg
was it was so shocking to me i expected
it to be way worse
yeah but it was really really good
that's why i feel like this movie
started off with a
really tight shitty budget right yeah
they filmed all this [ __ ]
then the pandemic hit and then hbo max
was like
all right give them like 50 million
dollars for their like cgi fee
like budget you know and so everything
else looked [ __ ] awesome
yeah yeah yeah it's one of those movies
that's like really bad but visually
like it works i i [ __ ] loved it i
don't know
i [ __ ] i was stuck with our [ __ ]
pg-13 mortal kombat movie for years
i'll i'll show it to my kid i'll show it
to my kid i'll show you guys both
yeah i was like this is what i got this
is what you get
it was so funny um i looked up on
google's one of the old
clips from the original mortal kombat
film and it was when luke king is
fighting reptile
right and then he [ __ ] bicycle kicks
his ass through the brick wall
and then they just cut to a scene where
he just turns into stone and then worms
out of his body
yeah it's the shittiest thing ever it
looks so bad right it looks like
playstation one it's
so bad you could see these long weird
polygon skins and the
lighting is all a hub it's absolutely
terrible dude
that's what we had so if you watched
that film and then you went to go see
the new one and then you were
you were [ __ ] trashing it for being
terrible yeah if you complain about that
reptile fight
compared to the old one ridiculous yeah
well that's why even with all these
terrible superman films
i'm also reminded of like the films that
we had when we were younger the
incredible hulk with lou ferrigno
that's one of the worst things you'll
ever see in your life yeah it's just a
normal human being that's green
i think the first great comic book
movie we got was blade oh right
oh that was like 98 97 98. yeah blade
was dope yeah
spawn okay yeah spawn well have you seen
it
again recently i've not seen it in over
10 years right
i think they're making a new one right
now actually um are they gonna do it
with michael j white though
no no i forget who's in it but the
director is the guy who created it
mcfarland oh really yeah
i forgot his first name but they're
making a new movie
and if you go back and try to watch
spawn again it doesn't hold up as well
as that oh really
yeah but there was john leguizamo and
[ __ ] he i know you this was a fat
[ __ ] clown yeah dead your d-e-d
dead for some reason i remember that
line i was just stupid [ __ ] line dude
i forgot about that
michael j white though man he was a [ __ ]
oh yeah he was a man
did you did you hear about that whole
little drama between michael j
white where the internet's very funny so
he was doing an interview with
uh vlad tv and there was the
the the topic of bruce lee being brought
up and
he asked do you think you'd be able to
beat up bruce lee he goes of course
yeah which the whole internet got pissed
at him he goes
there's absolutely no way michael jay
white would have beaten a bruce lee
and i'm like how how what are you
talking about
bruce lee was like five seven 125. yeah
135 maybe
like thirty-five 120 ripped though right
just ripped michael j white is six foot
two yeah 240 pounds yeah and also
knows he's also a lifetime martial arts
practitioner
that by the way has learned stuff from
bruce lee
yeah and the the martial arts because of
bruce lee has evolved since then
of course michael j white's going to
beat his ass yeah size difference
strength difference and he's an upgraded
version of bruce lee because
he was he's like really the the father
of mma yeah so if a bigger stronger guy
takes on the same
philosophy and teachings of bruce lee
like you ought to [ __ ] admire like
yeah
lift that up that's not him being cocky
these are just facts and like
well finding size doesn't matter why the
[ __ ] do they have weight classes in the
ufc that you
[ __ ] faces what are you talking about
size does matter
i think the problem was because i'm
guilty of a two i have
a big reverence for bruce lee right like
a
holy reference almost but we did we we
did
put bruce lee up on a pedestal kind of
thing where
we he is a legend now but he was a real
person
like us he's a legend i love and respect
bruce lee yeah a lot
bruce lee's right there that's bruce lee
hey
yeah [ __ ] bruce lee right there yeah
you know so
yeah but i mean it's the same problem
with once upon a time in hollywood
where people had a problem with they're
saying there's no way brad pitt
could beat up bruce lee it's not brad
pitt he's playing a [ __ ] character in
a movie
this is this so a lot of people also had
an issue
with that film and how bruce lee was
depicted right in this film
my argument to that was this it's a
[ __ ]
film it's not supposed to be a realistic
depiction of bruce lee
okay so then let's let's spoil it let's
talk about the ending what is the ending
about
ultimately it's about what if
charles manson and his crazy ass cult
went to the wrong house instead of
killing sharon tate
right they went to the wrong house right
so you start
breaking a movie down backwards whose
house
oh another actor right he would live
next door but at the bottom of the hill
and oh he's at the twilight of his
career yeah right and so he's going
through all this [ __ ]
so he has this friend who lives with him
a stunt double
well then who's this stunt double he's
an ex-marine
who's allegedly murdered his wife and
also
[ __ ] [ __ ] bruce lee right that's the
wrong [ __ ] house to go to not only
that he's high on acid
and he has a [ __ ] pitbull yeah the
other thing is he has
a [ __ ] flamethrower in his garage the
idea is
what if these people went to the wrong
house and the golden age of hollywood
never died because that's when hollywood
died right the golden age yeah
and then you start playing the movie
backwards and you start getting to know
these characters and you see at the end
quentin tarantino's just trying to make
a wish his dream come true
you know and through this film like
that's what his films are now you see
that yeah the style that he has with
them
are like if the golden age of hollywood
never
died yeah that's why tarantino has this
specific style
and that's why alvin kind of thinks that
his movies are all in the same universe
it's just storytelling guys you know
it's not a real bruce lee
yeah it didn't really happen it wasn't a
documentary it's crazy exactly
it wasn't a bruce lee biopic it was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
right yeah this is from a nation person
who literally has
a [ __ ] artwork of bruce lee that i
that's right there
you know what i mean so but i understand
too it's like sometimes
when it's somebody's childhood hero
they don't want that to be true yeah
right they don't want anybody
tarnishing the name whatsoever but it's
a [ __ ] film none of this [ __ ] is real
not real do you know what i'm saying
it's like people who get mad when they
have the conversation
dude i've i saw this video where i
literally wanted to
go into the comments and beat the [ __ ]
out of all these kids
like and i'm sorry they're not like
[ __ ] adults it was a video
about who would win goku or superman
and i've never seen so many angry people
right
so angry impossible when goku has this
this and that
you could see he could traverse through
planets in a second well superman
his power he gets when he goes closer to
the sun he could just take it up into
space and the closer he gets those rays
he'll
who the [ __ ] cares you know what you do
what it's like
it's probably like when your significant
other has a bad dream
where you did something [ __ ] up so
they're mad at you when they wake up
yeah you're like hey it's not real it
didn't really happen
exactly and it just happened to me
before by the way yeah
like that's the most ridiculous thing
it's like both of them are sticking
their fingers up their butt and saying
my [ __ ] smells more than yours
they're just putting this this [ __ ]
finger in both their faces like smell it
who's worse
mine's clearly worse who cares who cares
you have [ __ ] on your finger dude
shut up sometimes you just kind of gotta
ride out and like
enjoy it for what we have and then
you'll know like
because look we're in the age of reboots
too
they'll redo it they'll try again it's
it's just so funny too
i i don't understand people who talk
about combat sports who have never done
it is very odd you know
when they go size doesn't matter then
why would they ever have [ __ ] weight
classes dude
yeah why would they ever have it they
would just have it as a free-for-all
like in the first ufc yeah which was a
terrible idea
do you think the pound for pound can be
ridiculous sometimes
yeah that's hard to say yeah it's like
if mighty mouse
was like up there number two right up
against john jones
yeah who's going to win you know the the
hard conversation about the
pound-for-pound topic is based on the
fact that styles make up matches
yeah just because you're good in one
aspect it doesn't mean that somebody
else can take you down
so if i look at the pound for pound
thing i look for somebody who is
undeniably destroying people no matter
what style it is yes
and that one person to me that really
sticks out is habib nurmagomedov
right right no matter what style was put
up against him a wrestler
a grappler a jiu jitsu specialist a
striker
he mauled every single [ __ ] one
to me habib will always be the powerful
pound greatest
fighter the goat he will he to me he is
the goat because he's proved it
now you could say jon jones like well i
am right but there are times that you
have been vulnerable in your fights
habib has probably lost maybe one or two
fights in his whole career
rounds yeah in his whole [ __ ] career
and he has mauled every single person
so i think that's what we were saying
then like in mortal kombat
then if you're complaining about it this
and then maybe they should have just put
all mma fighters
in it yeah right then just put actually
have a khabib in there to actually fight
a mortal yeah why did they choose this
guy
who was a failing mixed martial arts
fighters when the habib
is right around the corner and he's just
like hey send location yeah if i was
right in i'd go hit up khabib
maybe so funny if he messed up and he
called it to lewistown he goes habib
nurmagomedov he goes
that's not me it's not me at all
couldn't i find jon jones dude i mean if
you want a realistic movie like that
then watch
warrior have you seen that one no uh
joel hbo
i don't know uh no it's a mma movie
not the asian american oh okay it's uh
joel edgerton and tom hardy
okay it's about a big mma tournament
and holy [ __ ] it's like the [ __ ]
rocky of mma
oh i gotta watch this solid it's so
[ __ ] soft it's worth buying too
yeah i get so weirded out when you said
warrior i was like i haven't seen that
i always get scared to watch asian
shows me too this there was one that
came out recently on the cw
which already wasn't going to be that
great because the cw yeah um
i say that only watch the why should i
get an audition physically
kidding that's dc superhero i'm just
kidding i actually watch a few cw shows
but
when it comes to asian stuff because
this is like the remake of the david
carradine
uh show kung fu kung fu yeah it's
one of the worst things i've ever seen
man i'm assuming the fight scenes look
just there so the main lead
i don't know who she is right uh
i don't have any connections towards her
so i'll say where the [ __ ] i want you're
probably a really nice person
but somebody told me that she was she
did an interview and she goes
i have no martial arts training
whatsoever and i'm so happy they took a
chance on me
and i saw that show and i'm like i
really wish they didn't because
you're hurt they should have cared
enough to at least
train you or actually make the camera
look like your martial arts are pretty
good
and also too because the argument behind
that show too it would be what
well it shouldn't be about that should
be about the story and the acting
both of them suck too so it's like what
the [ __ ] the and not not to the
actor's fault it's because the writing
is terrible right
the actors can't do much with that type
of writing i'm sorry that's what it is
it makes the actors look bad i guarantee
you if they get if you gave these actors
another script they'd [ __ ] kill it
yeah but
the writing is terrible so what were you
supposed to do with it and it got
renewed for a second season
[Laughter]
i mean that [ __ ] happens where i mean
people need to work
right and they're just going to take it
like the
guy who wrote the dragon ball movie had
to come out with an apology years later
right
because he was like you know at the time
that i wrote it i wasn't a fan
then later i became a fan and i realized
i [ __ ] it up
that's terrible you have to be a fan of
that stuff yeah yeah you have to
that's what happened they just hired
some hollywood writer and then
they told him right dragon ball and he
had no idea what it was about you know
that dragon ball movie had a korean pop
star on it
the g-o-d d-o-d yeah he was piccolo
right how
[ __ ] random yeah i always think
yeah yeah i would who the f i was like
what in the most random [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] did he get that role
i think it was a time when like b was in
movies too
he was rain right oh the the ninja yeah
yeah him
and like uh every now and then that
would be good
that movie could have been good that
ninja assassin movie i saw a few clips
of it something about it when sung
king's hands got cut off
yeah i was like uh i kind of put it off
that movie could have been good and it
just i mean it's
it's like it's one of those mortal
kombat things right right right it's a
ninja assassin thing just make the
action the most undeniable [ __ ] ever
yeah and make it work yeah but no
it didn't do any of that when people
look at those films and they ask for a
better story you shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] the story but what do you think
john wick was right
john wick was made the director who was
a
professional stunt person that showed
let me show you what the [ __ ] i can do
if i direct the film
right and that's what it's about you
know the premise of the first john wick
film is they killed his puppy
and now people are gonna get it that's
what the film is about it's just as
simple as that right and then the rest
of it is that bang bang bang bang and
the
stab stab stab i loved it
[Laughter]
it's it's just you don't you don't [ __ ]
with the guy and his puppy
and you you [ __ ] with the dude that's
already mentally unstable and now you
were the straw that broke the camel's
hump
and now you're gonna pay for it and
that's why you wanna put on
the these movies right we want to see
people get [ __ ] up
i don't know i'm sorry we like that [ __ ]
like are you asking for a great story
are you asking for
why can't you have both i was like
technically you can but this is
john wick yeah you're not i'm not
expecting anything else and that is some
of the best gun choreography i've ever
seen on
screen ever yeah like that maybe they
didn't have time to think about the
reason why he's going to shoot
besides anyone who's ever owned a dog
would understand
and it was that simple legit just calls
in the boogie man baba yaga
and like that's another thing it's not
there's a difference between
simplicity and then dumb too right yeah
like if
someone wants to call something dumb
because it's simple then i think you're
mistaken
yeah yeah john wick i'm telling you
loved it
so good yeah i love that [ __ ] well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
hope you guys enjoyed this one we talked
a little bit about film and some other
[ __ ]
uh yeah man i don't even know what the
[ __ ] we did yeah we were just talking
about a bunch of random [ __ ] before we
forgot we were supposed to talk about
apparently i'm in special ed
that that was a very weird revelation as
i was driving in my car
very odd well guys uh that wraps up this
episode you guys can catch us every
thursday and sundays
i'm sorry yeah it was a very weird
moment of my life
sorry okay yeah we're out here yeah
you can find ed at ed park vp of bible
study at momos
and then you'll find me crying looking
at my yearbook so i'll see y'all next
time peace